here with more reaction is the house
Intel Committee Chairman California
Congressman Devin Nunez freedom caucus
chairman North Carolina congressman mark
meadows neither were invited to my
Christmas party and I apologize for that
in half in retrospect I've been hearing
all night a lot and all day yesterday
that there's a possibility that that
struck page memos were actually handed
over to the State Department last week
and we haven't had them revealed
congressman meadows have you heard that
well really what we do know Shaun is
there there is another tranche of Peter
struck Lisa page text messages that
actually have been vetted by the DOJ and
we were just waiting on the Inspector
General to release those he gave that
release on Friday we've been expecting
those documents each and every day as of
tonight as of right now we don't have
those we have let our displeasure be
known to the DOJ official so hopefully
we'll receive those tomorrow yeah you
know why don't we get the whole batch I
don't understand the slow roll
congressman Nunez I got to give you a
lot of credit it always comes to a
crisis and then rod Rosen sees in the
last second just for whatever reason
he'll finally hand it over after he
begged Paul Ryan not to hand over what
became the Nunez memo sir you said went
to Maria Bartiromo this weekend that
there was no intelligence none as the
basis for the start of this Russia probe
let me let me start by saying to what to
Mark's point they shouldn't wait they
need to enforce the subpoenas
immediately mr. Gowdy and mr. Goodlatte
the more that you wait over time I've
learned that you just wait and you wait
and you wait and pretty soon there'll be
an election and I think the Department
of Justice and the FBI are banking on
the Democrats taking over so that all
these investigations can be shut down as
it relates to what I said over the
weekend it remains true we have not seen
any five eyes intelligence any credible
intelligence that started this
investigation it's why we're
investigating the State Department
unbuffered not for a number of reasons
alright let me ask you both is it gonna
take a contempt order from Carl they're
going to be holding contempt at the
Justice Department because I agree with
your analysis it seems they trying to
push this to 2018 see if Democrats get
control well I think Sean one of the
things chairman Nunez has done an
unbelievable job not only investigating
this but keeping the pressure on and
it's not unless that pressure is really
felt by DOJ officials that they actually
produce anything and I've been on the
phone most of the day with them I don't
understand why it's taking such
unbelievable Herculean efforts to get
them to do that but we've notified the
the White House as well you know
it'sit's this president's DOJ why why
are they not produced two documents and
let us do our oversight congressman no
that's your thoughts and what what is it
going to take well I do think we're to
the point where the Congress has to
exercise its full authority so immediate
subpoenas immediate contempt if you have
to move to impeachment do that now as
Mark just said as mr. meadows just said
I do believe that the president at this
point should step in should take his
authority as the executive officer of
this country and make sure that the
United States Congress has provided all
of this documentation immediately and
that's only because just look at all of
the examples that are out there that go
back a year and a half now that we were
stalled on and just tonight you broke
news again if it is true that mr.
Richmond was an employee of the FBI
that's something we had no idea we did
not know that now don't you think and we
should have known that since we've been
investigating this for a year and a half
I have I have to run and up to three
people may have gotten this information
I want to thank you both because you're
fighting for the truth and I know you
both have taken a lot of heat for it and
the American people deserve and thank
you all for being with us congressman
meadows congressman Devin Nunez